tonight we celebrate the life of regis
philbin
i'm so proud to say that he was a dear
friend of our show
and you know what so many people felt
close to regis
because for decades they welcomed him
into their homes it's
hard to to explain but when but when you
spend your life
in front of a camera
i can't talk right now
a couple of times along the way when i
thought it was over but you hang in
there you got bills to pay you just hope
for uh the right opportunity and it
finally came it happened when i
when i came back here to new york what
do you think gang you like it
whoever can make it in this business god
bless them we're all overpaid anyway
we're all lucky to be here
regis family shared the sad news over
the weekend
the tv icon passed away friday night of
natural causes
just one month shy of his 89th birthday
this morning kelly and ryan shared a
special tribute
you always know that some certain things
are inevitable
and passing away is one of those things
but regis is one of
the people that we all believed i think
would
somehow figure out a way around the
inevitable i got presents today from
regis
yeah she goes she got a free mug and a
free money got a picture of regis
that's right he's fun to work with every
day is
the best before kelly regis spent 15
years sharing the mic
and the laughs with kathleen gifford
live
they came over about two weeks ago i saw
reach get out of the car with joy and
i'd sensed
some much more fragility than i'd seen
in him since the last time in january
out in los
angeles we just had the best time and
after they left i just thought to myself
lord is that the last time i'm going to
see my friend because he was failing i
could tell
this is it for entertainment tonight to
sing miss america huh
here she is
i'm thankful for my kathy lee and the
success of our
show i'm so thankful i never have to
look at this outfit again
everywhere i look e.t following my every
move
it's true e.t interviewed regis more
than 200 times across four decades
our first interview was in 1981 when he
launched his first national show
the regis philbin show i have kind of a
sense of humor that i hope everybody
understands by now i
i hope the nation will understand it
shortly i don't mean to bury anybody but
i do mean to have fun with them and kid
them
and i expect that in return tributes to
the hardest working man in showbiz
poured in
as celebrities remembered his 60-year
career david letterman said
when he retired i lost interest in
television i love him
and from jimmy kimmel a tv legacy that
will likely go unmatched
you know brad pitt won't leave me alone
honest to god
everywhere i go brad pitt is there
george clooney is here
we're sitting with george george
requested
what am i gonna say no to george of
course i'll sit with you
tom cruise look at schwarzenegger is
this is this the kind of thing like
regis is in town move over crews could
never handle this role many people are
going to thank me for their career in
this business how many boom bots
including you
joking aside regis did discover a
special member of the entertainment
tonight family
i discovered mary hart i saw her on
channel 11 i said i may get a show on
nbc and if i do
you're the girl i want and it happened
unfortunately
the show went down in flames i was out
of work for a year but mary hart went to
work the next day
doing entertainment tonight thank you
behind the scenes
regis also faced some health issues in
1993 he had heart surgery
and in 2007 a triple bypass nobody wants
to go to the hospital
that's my initial reaction but i guess i
gotta go
but the easy to love host with the quick
win always bounced back
as host of who wants to be a millionaire
30 million viewers a night
tuned in to hear him say final answer
this is the show
that saves the abc television network
that resurrects it
that makes it a network again this show
right here the successful game show
landed him in the record books for
having the most
hours on tv nearly 17 000 filled with
laughter
warm and fun i have no regrets
i received an opportunity to do
something that i always wanted to do
and some people go through their whole
careers and never get that chance
e.t last spoke with regis in january he
was working with one of his four
children jj
an executive producer of single parents
executive producer
he's tough which is good since the show
began
we've been thinking what is the way that
we can bring regis philbin
onto this show you got a signal i'm
trying to phone a friend
fortunately you said yes oh yeah well
jj followed her dad into hollywood regis
gave his full support
i'm very proud i know what it's like to
start at the bottom i started as a page
and then a stagehand here in hollywood
she's made great uh great moves over the
last
four years she's on her way this is the
first time i've written anything like
the words that are going to come out of
his mouth
boy it's better to get screams too it
better get big laughs that's a lot of
pressure
you gotta have an answer to this one all
i asked was how you doing
it's just such a thrill to have him
on on my show after you know years and
years of
being a guest on his show and i just you
know i hope he
has as much fun on our set as i did on
on his growing up
yes regis loved to show off his family
we're also pretty good at expecting a
curveball
from dad and sort of rolling with it
nobody embellishes the story though
better than regis
none of us couldn't do that so he's
never had a problem we stick mostly to
the truth
laughter was always the bond especially
in regis and joy's 50-year marriage
what's the matter with you of course i'm
cooking
oh yeah regis is a lot of help in the
kitchen pour that in see
their chemistry was effortless of course
that made joy an obvious candidate to
take over after kathy lee's departure
from live in 2000
but she declined one reason if they had
a disagreement before a show
they wouldn't be able to fake it for the
camera joy doesn't want it do you do it
no we have personal reasons why we don't
think that would be a good idea
don't we yeah yeah let's play bigoted
besides a strong marriage and date
nights out just before the quarantine
regis also credits joy for his prime
time game show gig
she said you know you're coming home
early in the afternoon maybe there's
something you can do in the afternoon
all of a sudden i saw the show i said
yeah i think this is a cute show
maybe it'll go once in a while regis
family may have put it best saying that
they are
forever grateful for his singular
ability to make every day into something
worth talking about
and that's his final answer
[Music]
you